GUEST SPEAKER: Great.
Thank you very much,
everyone, for the opportunity
to present some
of the strategies
that we can use to influence
federal policy making in
regards to renewable energy.
So first of all,
I'm just give you,
just going to give you a brief
overview of the presentation
today.
So first, I'm going
to talk a little bit
about some background
information
about climate change regulation
here in the United States.
Then I'm going to give
you a general overview
about the policy making process.
And with that, I'm going to
give you specific strategies
that we can use to employ
and increase employments
over federal policy making.
So just briefly, the three
strategies are, first one,
take advantage of the
political momentum.
The second one is to
frame climate change
as both an energy issue
and as a health issue.
And the third one
will be to focus
on tax credit for investments
in renewable energy production.
So as a way of a
background, as you know,
renewable resources and
climate change regulation
are closely linked.
So unfortunately,
climate change regulation
is, congressional action on
climate change is stalled.
However, the federal
government and President Obama,
more specifically, recently
proposed regulation to cut--
and the wording is,
carbon pollution
from power plants
in 30% by 2030.
So this is a very
big opportunity.
And as you can see
in the diagram,
I'm just going to talk about
three phases, if you will.
There are more
phases after that.
But it's agenda setting, policy
formulation, policy option.
So the first thing that
you, that's important
is that this is
not a sequential--
line of-- policy making.
Even though we do have some
legislation on renewable energy
and tax credit, we
are still, we still
have to take advantage of
the agenda setting phase
and the policy formulation
and the policy adoption.
So the first strategy
that I talked
about before, which
is take advantage
of the political momentum,
is that we have to make sure
that we take advantage of
the fact that climate change
is now permanent in
the media, not only
because of this announcement
of this new push for regulation
of power plant emission.
But also-- we have to make sure
that the United Nations climate
summit creates also
this opportunity for us
to put this, the action
on renewable energy
and the political agenda.
The second strategy will be
to frame renewable energy
as both a climate change
issue and a health issue.
So as I said before,
President Obama's announcement
was targeting health
issues, or climate change
as a public health issue.
So I think that's
an interesting way
to frame our policy
proposals and use
this framing that
was already given
by the federal government.
But we can use it
in our advantage.
By reducing fossil fuel
use, we can actually
increase public health.
So also, just remembering
that the issue is already
part of the
institutional agenda,
meaning that renewable
energy and tax
credit for renewable
energy production
is already part of the
institutional agenda
because there's already
regulation in place.
Unfortunately, the tax
credit will expire by 2016.
So we need to make sure that
it continues in the agenda
and propose the tax credit
in the policy formulation
and make sure that is
adopted after it expires.
So just briefly, I'm
just going to give you
five reasons why a tax
credit is a important policy
instrument in this case.
First of all, it's the only
issue that you all agree on.
So I think the fact that
this coalition actually
has a consensus on
one policy instrument
is a very important
political tool
that we can use to actually
tell Congress, well,
this is what we agree
on, all sides of--
this issue.
And second, there is
no direct expenditure.
So basically, tax
credit is an investment.
There is no additional
expenditure.
Third, it's easier to
administrate because we already
have the institutional
framework in place.
And we already have
tax credits anyway.
It's not a new, a
brand new proposal.
And fourth, it's technically
and politically feasible.
So we just have to make
sure that we tell Congress
that there's regulations
already in place.
It's, renewable energy
is technically feasible.
And so we just need
more incentives
to actually invest
in renewable energy
and make sure that better
regulation that was proposed
by President Obama actually
has a positive impact
on renewable energy production.
Thank you.